el día del amor se siente en el ambiente
bueno te has paola el vida supervisa la
recolección de rosas en un cultivo en
nemocón a una hora de bogotá la capital
de colombia en las charlas con sus
trabajadoras en sueñan con las historias
de amor detrás de los pétalos tanto no
sé
hasta dónde llegará a nuestra florecita
si también vivir bonito y porque por eso
uno se dedica día a día uno se dedica a
cuidarlas para que todo esté bien para
dar un buen producto y que vayan a
tocarla
en esta plantación cultivan 60 especies
de rosas diferentes en total en la
sabana de bogotá trabajan más de 100 mil
personas en su mayoría mujeres elvira
lleva 33 años en la empresa toda su vida
dedicada al negocio todo mi tiempo y
todo mi amor al trabajo lo he dedicado a
las flores porque las flores también me
transmiten eso he podido llegar y lograr
tener mis cosas y mis objetivos y metas
que he podido lograr es a través de
ellas a través de ese de este hermoso
trabajo de las flores las empresas de
flores colombianas cumplen con la
demanda internacional pero cada vez les
cuesta más encontrar empleados buenos
días enero y febrero ante la llegada de
san valentín son los meses de mayor
volumen de trabajo las largas jornadas
laborales y la dureza expandan a los
jóvenes
porque trabajamos más de las 8 horas
bien en las horas extras y entonces ahí
la gente se cansa un poquito porque está
trabajando más de sus 8 horas
cansancio que permite que colombia
exporte en estos días
650 millones de tallos en más de 100
países en 2021 el país registró mil 544
millones de dólares en exportaciones de
flores es la cifra más alta de la
historia para ello se necesita una
logística de la que dependen ministerios
aduanas y empresas se organizan en el
plan pétalo carolina pantoja es su
directora reivindica el valor de la rosa
para colombia lo que cortamos de
colombia con sentimientos a estos países
queremos reforzar experiencias
inspiradoras para que los consumidores
finales puedan expresar su sentimiento y
puedan disfrutar de las flores
colombianas al transmitir lo que quieren
y lo que sienten a través de una flor
vamos en facatativá 45 kilómetros de
bogotá está gladys pertenece al
sindicato nacional de trabajadores del
sistema agroalimentario
durante seis años trabajo en las flores
desde hace una década asesora y acompaña
a otras trabajadoras del sector gladys
se encuentra en la sede sindical con
marco antonio un compañero de luchas
preparan su particular 14 de febrero
porque le vamos a poner ve a la idea es
ponerle aquí el rótulo donde diga feliz
día de los trabajadores y trabajadores
de las flores desde 2003 antes
significado el día de san valentín
muchos trabajadores valen más que una
flor vamos a colocar el reto actual
marco antonio también trabajo en el
sector y tiene familiares a los que no
ve desde hace más de un mes y decís la
explotación del exceso de trabajo el
maltrato son
tranquilamente 18 20 horas seguidas y
sobre todo en post cosechar cuando el
ritmo la gente no tiene no tiene ni
siquiera oportunidad de dormir en
poscosecha la gente se está quedando y
los jóvenes las nuevas generaciones de
hoy no quieren llegar
las flores denuncias que aseguran ningún
trabajador se atreve a hacer frente a
cámara por miedo por eso marco antonio
rechaza el lema del plan pétalo está
diciendo que colombia exporta
sentimientos pues aquí me yo me pregunto
qué tipo de sentimiento se exporta
colombia son unas flores que ya se ha
dicho le porta atrás que hay en toda la
situación de los de las trabajadores y
trabajadores y exportar sentimientos es
exportar dólares para los para los
empresarios para gladys esos
sentimientos perpetuas lógicas
patriarcales 'san valentín' incendiarios
inauguradas entonces
y digamos que está sucia no se ha
enseñado ese amor romántico
donde todo tiene que ser bonito de todo
es tu dulce donde se celebra con una
flor y la flor de un sentimiento qué
romántico y detrás de eso es una
realidad muy muy compleja
estas rosas colombianas pronto llegarán
a eeuu europa y japón
los enamorados las han buscado a lo
largo de la historia es el símbolo del
amor pero en colombia sólo el 50% de las
exportaciones tienen el certificado de
buenas prácticas